[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday February 24th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
today it marks one year since Russia
invaded Ukraine the war's toll shows on
Ukraine's people its infrastructure and
its once thriving Tech sector
last summer I spoke to some Ukrainian
Tech CEOs about how the war had impacted
their businesses and what they thought
their sector's future was I caught up
with one of them Oleg roginski CEO and
founder of people AI a few days ago
people AI is based in California but it
had a lot of employees in Ukraine before
the war many of them have relocated to
Prague or Toronto for those who stayed
the war has created extra challenges we
obviously have introduced additional
security protocols for the few folks who
are still in Ukraine in terms of them
being far from the front lines their
systems being secured and obviously if
the security situation changes we have
an ability to remotely kind of lock
things down wipe them and make sure that
the customer data security is preserved
at all times but also definitely there
is impact on employees in terms of
rolling blackouts inability to work and
work time Etc and so we sent in
batteries we are trying to help as much
as we can but there are definitely
physical limitations to how Ukraine
operates from business perspective right
now Tech has defined this war from the
sector it shook up to the tools used to
fight it and the ways it's being
captured and shared across the world in
fact smartphones have made this the most
intensely documented war in history
with us to discuss the impact of that is
Stephen Fiddler wsj bureau chief at
large in London hi Stephen thanks for
joining us my pleasure let's talk about
some of the ways smartphones are being
used first by militaries for armies are
these new tools of War they're fairly
new they're being used in several ways
to find Targets and locate targets both
are sort of unwittingly and wittingly if
you like unwittingly the use of
smartphones by Russian soldiers on the
front has allowed Ukrainian forces to
geo-locate concentrations of troops and
Target them so essentially that sort of
poor Battlefield security if you like
but it has allowed them to do this and
of course this isn't the first world war
in which that has happened there's also
been a help by if you like partisans or
ordinary citizens in occupied
territories using smartphones to locate
Four Ukrainian forces concentrations of
of troops and I mean conditioned and
that kind of thing and that's an issue
that sort of blurs if you like the
difference between combatants and
civilians in Warfare but it has been
something that has been used by the
ukrainians significantly during the war
are the Russians using this as well are
they taking advantage of geolocation
technology for example it's hard to say
I suspect that's true one thing that
seems to have happened is that the
operational security of the ukrainians
has seemed to be better than that of the
Russians Ukrainian forces seem less
likely to be using cell phones at the
front or Smartphones at the front less
likely to be phoning home and that kind
of thing of course it's probably
impossible to stop this with an army but
it does seem that the ukrainians you
know in terms of security have been
rather better at this than the Russians
what about out the role of social media
because I mean that's a big reason we go
on to our smartphones
absolutely I think it's been an enormous
factor in the war really and it's helped
people I think very broadly to
understand what's going on in the
battlefields in ways that probably
weren't widely understood before they
also provide an element for propaganda
as well as disseminating facts a lot of
the sort of narrative of the war if you
like has come through platforms like
Facebook but Facebook is banned in
Russia so there are specific platforms
there you know one called food contact
day which is used in Russia as like
Facebook and another one called telegram
which is widely used in Russia and in
Ukraine this is a barely curated
platform with very kind of little
censorship on what goes on that's not
like Twitter or and that kind of thing
so there are all kinds of outpourings
available on telegram of atrocities but
other things that you know many of which
violate the Geneva conventions but they
have provided enormous kind of amount of
footage and helped create create the
narrative the widely understood
narrative that we have of the war so so
this armies those who are involved in
the war posting on
it is both so it's everyday ukrainians
obviously we see quite a lot from um you
know what happens when there are attacks
on Targets in Kiev in the capital but
we're also seeing stuff from the front
lines I suspect that's more shall we say
curated by the Ukrainian military
authorities so they get a narrative out
and the same is true of the Russians but
again I think the Russians have probably
been less disciplined in this and we see
quite often elements that come from the
Russian side that are probably not
conducive or not very helpful to the
Russians in the conduct of the war but
yeah both civilians and soldiers you you
mentioned smartphones and social media
being used to potentially document war
crimes you know a few months ago on the
show we had a conversation about the
smartphones being used in this way in
Ukraine but one issue has been just the
amount of data that's being collected by
so many smartphones on the battlefield
how are the groups who are getting this
information dealing with that
overwhelming amount of data coming in
you're absolutely right that's a huge
issue for them one of the groups that
I've talked to it's called mnemonics and
it's a berlin-based non-profit that is
documented attempting to document war
crimes and it has a sister organization
in Syria and in Syria over the course of
say 11 years they have about five
million pieces of recordings and and
other things videos of the war which
they have archived so far in a year of
war in Ukraine they have 2.8 million and
this is years of footage for someone to
sit down and look at all that would take
years but they're sort of archiving and
giving a special sort of identity so it
can't be subsequently altered and as
well as looking at it manually if
they're using Technologies like computer
vision sort of artificial intelligence
and machine learning to try to identify
key elements of the footage these are
things that will develop will become
probably better at the tasks that
they're supposed to do and groups like
mnemonics are hoping that this will
allow for a kind of Reckoning in
possible war crimes tribunals at the end
of the war all right that was Stephen
Fiddler thanks for joining us Stephen
you're welcome
who's briefing this week tnb's producer
is Julie Chang our supervising producer
is Melanie Roy and our executive
producer is Chris Tinsley I'm your host
Zoe Thomas thanks for listening and have
a great weekend
[Music]